Gerne, gerne.
Bitte schön.
Danke.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich bin der Diensthabende Arzt heute.
Ich kümmere mich um Sie.
Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Helene Berger.
Helene Berger.
Können Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname für mich stabilieren?
Ja, das sind lauter E's.
H E L E N E.
E.
So, E, wie immer.
H E, H E, L E, L E.
Okay.
Und der ist B E R.
G E R.
Okay, Berger.
So, sage ich.
Richtig.
Okay, Frau Berger.
Bevor wir über Ihre schweren Spuren,
bitte ich gerne einfach allgemeine Fragen der Sie stellen zu.
Ich bin noch 62 Jahre alt.
Ich werde im Sommer 63 Jahre alt.
Über Ihre Geburtstattung.
12.6. 1959.
12.6.
59.
Wie groß sind Sie, Frau Berger?
Ja, 1 Meter 64 bin ich.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
84 Kilo.
Aber ich habe auch ein bisschen zugenommen in letzter Zeit.
Ja, es passiert.
Mit Corona.
Sind wir alle eigentlich in so genommen.
Was machen Sie, Berofe?
Ich bin Frührennerin.
Aber was war Ihre Büro?
Ich habe als Hausmeisterin gearbeitet.
Was kann ich für die Küche kümmern?
Ja, also, ich habe so, so.
Wenn ich mich ein bisschen anstrenge,
wenn ich Treppen hochgehe,
habe ich das Gefühl,
dass ich nicht mehr gut Luft bekomme.
Und wenn ich nur eine Etage hochgelaufen bin,
fängt das schon an.
Und ich habe mir das jetzt auch angewöhnt,
dass ich nachts mir noch ein zweites Kissen hole.
Um ein bisschen höher zu schlafen,
weil ich das Gefühl habe,
dass ich sonst so schlecht Luft bekomme
und so ein Engelgefühl habe.
Ein bisschen kuscheln muss ich auch.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Büro?
Ja, das hat so angefangen vor gut einem Monat,
vielleicht so fünf, sechs Wochen.
Erst habe ich mir da nichts beigedacht.
Ich habe vielleicht ein bisschen Husten oder so,
aber das wird irgendwie gar nicht besser.
Und haben Sie auch Schmerzen?
Ja, so richtig dolles Schmerzen würde ich jetzt vielleicht nicht sagen.
Das ist mir so dieses Gefühl,
dass es so eng wird in der Brust.
Und ich habe das Gefühl,
ich habe das Gefühl,
es wird so gefährlich.
Und was mir auch aufgefallen ist,
wenn ich mich ein bisschen anstrengte,
wenn ich mich bücke
oder wenn ich was sauber mache in der Wohnung
und mich ein bisschen mehr anstrengte Betten beziel,
dass ich dann merke,
jetzt muss ich aber eine Pause machen.
Weil mir schwindelig ist.
Okay.
Passierst du kurz zusammen, ob ich etwas nicht verpassen möchte.
Und Sie haben seit sechs Wochen diese Enggefühl, wenn Sie sich belasten.
Wirklich?
Wenn ich mich belaste, ja.
Und Sie schlafen mit zwei Kisten.
Kissen, ja.
Und Sie können nicht mehr, mehr als eine Tage Treppe hochgehen, ohne Pause machen.
Ja, genau, so ist das.
Okay.
Haben Sie das erst mal seit sechs Wochen bemerkt, aber vorher könnten Sie ganz ruhig
so zwei oder drei Etagen hochgehen und mit der Belastung...
Ja, also ich hatte schon mal eine Phase, wo das auch ein bisschen war, aber man hat dann festgestellt,
das ist jetzt schon über ein halbes Jahr her, dass ich ein bisschen Vorhofflimmern habe.
Aber und der Blutdruck ist auch immer ein bisschen hoch, aber dass das jetzt so schlecht ist, das habe ich noch nicht erlebt.
Okay, Frau Berger.
Und ich würde gerne eine andere Frage stellen, so wie Sie gesagt haben, so Ihre Vorerkanntungen.
Sie haben schon das gesagt, vor sechs Monaten haben Sie Vorhofflimmern erfasst.
Ja, da hat man das festgestellt.
Und haben Sie deswegen eine OP, in einem OP gelandet oder...
Nein, nein, das hat man nur beim EKG festgestellt und das war auch nicht so doll.
Aber ich soll halt jetzt mehr Medikamente nehmen.
Okay, Sie nehmen etwas ein?
Ja, ich nehme ganz viel verschiedene Sachen.
Ich nehme Markumare, eine halbe Tablette und dann nehme ich Bio Proloel, eine Tablette
und dann habe ich noch, was das heißt, HCT 12,5.
Dann nehme ich auch eine davon.
Dann nehme ich noch Lisinopril und Atua Vastatin.
Und Sie haben schon das...
Auch bald fast Frühstück mehr, weil ich so viele Tabletten nehme.
Ja, ich verstehe manchmal ist das ja ein bisschen schwierig,
aber diese alle Medikamente sind wichtig für Ihre Gesundheit.
Und dann, Sie haben schon das gesagt, dass Sie an die Hochblutdruck leiden.
Ja, der Blutdruck ist ein bisschen hoch, genau.
Und wann haben Sie die?
Ach, das ist bestimmt schon 7, 8 Jahre.
Ja, und auch die Fettwerte im Blut sind auch nicht so gut.
Das ist auch immer ein bisschen erhöht.
Das hat man aber erst vor 3 Jahren so festgestellt.
Aber die weitere Erkrankungen?
Zum Beispiel...
Ja, ich hatte mal vor, das ist aber auch schon lange her,
hatte ich mal eine Bauchspeicheltruhsendenentzündung.
Das war eine sehr schmerzhafte Angelegenheit.
Da bin ich froh, dass das wieder vorbei ist.
Und das scheint aber auch gut gegangen zu sein.
Okay.
Und dann habe ich, ja, das ist auch mit einer der Gründe,
weshalb ich nicht mehr arbeiten kann.
Ich habe eine Knieersatz bekommen, ein Kniegelenkersatz.
Das ist auch schon 10 Jahre her.
Aber das rechte Knie, das ging irgendwie gar nicht mehr.
Und dann habe ich dann eine Knieprothese bekommen.
Und die OP war ganz komplikationlos?
Bitte was?
Ihre OP würde Knieersatz, so ganz komplikationlos?
Das ist gut gelaufen, ja, ja, da gab es keine Schwierigkeiten.
Ja, ja, ja.
Normalerweise.
Weitere OP.
Also, sonst war nichts klein.
Ist Ihre Geschichte in Ihrem Leben,
haben Sie schon mal einen Unfall passiert?
Nein, einen Unfall hatte ich nicht.
Sind Ihnen gegen bestimmte Medikamente oder bestimmte Pflanzen
Allergien bekannt?
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich, das hat man mal festgestellt,
gegen Amoxicillin eine Allergie.
Da muss ich aufpassen.
Da kriege ich so einen Hautausschlag.
Und dann ist auch ein bisschen lästig.
Ich habe so eine Hausstaubmilbenallergie.
Da kriege ich so tüchtige Schnupflase.
Über Ihre wichtige Beschwerden.
Ich wollte gerne fragen, vor sechs Wochen,
hatten Sie irgendwie eine Infektion, Erkaltungen,
so erinnert sich die...
Kann ich mich nicht erinnern, dass da etwas war?
Ein Infektor, kann ich mich nicht erinnern?
Okay.
Haben Sie Fieber vorbeigegangen?
Nein, ich fühle mich nicht fieberig.
Ich habe aber auch nicht gemessen,
aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich Fieber habe.
Okay.
Ich habe schon gesagt, dass Sie zugenommen sind.
Wir haben das gemessen, z.B. die viele Kilo.
Ja, das sind, glaube ich, so zwei bis drei Kilo,
die jetzt noch oben draufgekommen sind in letzter Zeit.
Wie ist Ihre Schlaf?
Ich muss nachts oft auf die Toilette gehen.
Manchmal zweimal.
Und dann schläft man natürlich nicht so gut.
Also einmal eigentlich fast jede Nacht
und manchmal sogar zweimal.
Und dadurch bin ich immer,
ja, bin ich dann auch müde am nächsten Tag.
Okay.
Waren Sie zwar weiter?
Nicht mehr.
Bis vor sechs Jahren habe ich geraucht, wirklich lange.
Aber ja, nicht so wahnsinnig viel,
halbes Päckchen am Tag.
Die fieber ich?
Ja, fast 40 Jahre.
Und Sie haben schon das gesagt,
fünf Jahre vorher haben Sie das aufgehört.
Seit sechs Jahren rauch ich nicht mehr.
Sechs Jahre, okay, schön.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Na ja, Alkohol, also 2, 3 Gläser Bier am Abend trinke ich Folie.
Jeder Abend?
Ja, zum Abendessen und dann nochmal so beim Fernsehen
oder wenn man zusammensitzt, ja, da trinke ich doch fast jeden Abend, würde ich sagen.
Ja, ich kann das verstehen, man sollte das Leben auch genießen.
Bitte, was?
Ich kann das total verstehen, man sollte das Leben auch genießen.
Ja, ja, genau.
Okay, dann, diese Frage kann ein bisschen unangenehm sein,
aber es geht nicht um Sie,
so ich muss diese Frage,
jede Patiente und Patiente stellen.
So, in Ihrem Leben haben Sie irgendwann mit den Drogen Kontakt gehabt?
Nee, mit Drogen habe ich nie was zu tun gehabt.
Nein, nein.
Wie viele Geschwister haben Sie vorab?
Ich habe keine Geschwister.
Sind Sie allein?
Ich war allein.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Mutter lebt noch, aber mein Vater ist gestorben.
Warum?
Mein Vater hatte, ja, der ist 80 geworden, der hatte Knochenkrebs.
Okay, die Mutter ist gesund, oder hat sie auch?
Ja, bis vor drei Jahren war die auch gesund,
aber jetzt hat die irgendwie ein Tumor im Unterleib,
ich weiß gar nicht, Eierstöcke oder Gebärmutter oder so,
irgendwie da in dem Bereich hat die einen Tumor.
Aber ist behandelt worden und operiert worden
und jetzt geht es ihr so weit ganz gut.
Okay.
Und sind Sie allein oder mit Ihrem Familien?
Ich bin alleine und ja, so bin ich verwitzt.
Und meine Kinder, da ist einer den Betreuch wohl noch,
aber der wohnt nicht bei mir.
Ich lebe also alleine. Bitte?
Wie viele Kinder haben Sie?
Drei habe ich.
Und haben Sie Ihre Kinder mit normalen Geburt gehabt?
Das waren alles normale Entbindungen, ja.
Und sind Sie auch gesund?
Ja, der eine Sohn hatte einen schweren Motorradunfall
und ist dadurch pflegeabhängig
und ist aber wohnt aber nicht bei mir,
aber ich muss mich viel um den kümmern
und habe natürlich auch ein bisschen Sorgen um den.
Es tut mir leid so, es tut mir schwer sein.
Okay. Ich bin durch mit meinem Fragenfahrebeiger,
so, möchten Sie etwas hinterbegehen?
Vielleicht habe ich etwas vergessen
oder möchten Sie etwas hinterbegehen?
Sie haben so viel gefragt,
ich wüsste gar nicht mehr, was ich Ihnen noch erzählen kann.
Ich glaube, jetzt möchte ich eigentlich nur noch wissen,
was man dagegen tun kann und woanders liegen kann.
Und wie man das feststellen kann, woanders liegt,
das wären jetzt so meine Fragen.
Okay.
Ich muss erst mal Ihnen so körperlich untersuchen
und danach muss ich die Blut abnehmen.
Aber ich kann so weit zeigen,
Ihre Beschwerden liegt an Ihrem Herz oder Ihrem Lungen,
aber Sie müssen jetzt nicht große Sorgen dafür machen.
Wir müssen erst mal die EKG und die Rundchenschale aufmachen.
Dann können wir am Ende mit der alle befunden,
nochmal mit Ihnen spielen.
Okay. Ja, dann will ich mich mal gedulden.
Okay. Danke schön.
Gut.
Sorry, wenn ich etwas vergessen habe, das war meine zweite Mal.
Ehrlich?
Ja, das war meine zweite Erhebung.
Diese? Unglaublich. Ja, nicht gut.
Hab ich meine erste Annämpfung heute ein paar Stunden vorher gehabt.
Okay.
Ein Stresstag.
Ja. Okay.
Eine Frage kam von Dr. Alici.
Ich habe eine Frage nach dem Vorruflemann.
Ist das damit geklärt?
Ja, deswegen habe ich das nicht gehört.
Deswegen habe ich gefragt.
Eine hat von uns geantwortet.
Vielen Dank.
Möchtest du noch jemanden fragen, Dr. Gündig?
Ich habe mich mit der Regelmäßigkeit geholfen.
Sie haben Marcomas bekommen.
Das wurde regelmäßig kontrolliert.
Aber nur das.
Wer hat das geholfen?
Ich habe das geholfen.
Enden in Sicht.
Die Werte, da müssen Sie bei meinem Haus dranrufen.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Okay.
Ja, eine Frage kam gerade rein.
Die ist tatsächlich nicht gefragt worden.
Und da hätte sie positiv geantwortet.
Die Beine, das ist ihr aufgefallen sind, tatsächlich geschwollen.
Aber normalerweise würde ich erst mit den körperlichen Untersuchungen
machen.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie Leute in Deutschland,
aber in der Türkei sind.
Ich habe fast nie gehört, dass meine Patientin,
dass ich meine Beine auf meine Beine geschwollen habe.
Wahrscheinlich haben wir ja die Kardiolobe-Kolleginnen.
Im Fall ist es beschrieben,
dass sie das als ein Symptom hat.
Aber ich habe das jetzt nicht als ein Toppunkt mit genannt.
Das ist ja eines von vielen Sachen, die es eben auch gibt.
Und wenn sie gefragt hätten, hätte ich es vielleicht gesagt.
Husten habe ich gesagt.
Husten habe ich gesagt, dass ich oftmals so komischen Husten habe.
Genau.
Wir haben eigentlich das Programm komplett durch.
Alles, was man fragen kann, ist gefragt.
Selman hat gut durchgebräht.
Neue Arzt.
Heute ist es ein zweiter Fall.
Zum zweiten Mal.
Ich denke, Selman braucht eine gute Reaktion.
Aber gute Reaktionen, z.B. dieser Fall ist ein Notfallfall.
Und die Patienten sagt, dass es ein Engige fühlt.
Stimmt, ja.
Danach durchschnell wie möglich ein EKG schreiben.
Und dann weiter reden.
Und weiter reden.
Aber doch auf jeden Fall.
Ich habe gedacht, dass sie seit sechs Wochen diese Beschwerden hat.
Nicht jetzt.
Sie hat nicht gesagt, dass sie gerade einen Notfall hat.
Kein Problem, Selman.
Das ist alles, diese Situation, Notfall.
Diese Patienten 20 Mal ein Notfall gehen.
Erste Mal EKG schreiben.
Okay, okay.
Und die Parameter müssen wir kontrollieren.
Ich glaube, wenn die Patientin jetzt überzeugender krank gespielt hätte.
Wenn ich jetzt so, ich kriege überhaupt gar keine Luft mehr,
der wahrscheinlich anders reagiert.
Aber ich weiter mache.
Sofort machen wir das zweite Fälle.
Okay.
Okay, meine Operatoren habe ich heute eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne mit ihnen diese Fälle diskutieren.
Haben Sie bei mir?
Ja, erzählen Sie mal, was Sie gerade gesehen haben.
Okay.
Helena Berger, 62-jährige Patientin.
Sie ist ein bisschen übergewicht.
Sie lagen über die Luftnot, wenn sie sich belastet.
Sie hat schon das gesagt.
Sie kann nicht mehr ohne Pause mehr als eine Etage auf die Kreppe
aufgehen kann.
Und sie musste auch mit den zwei Schlüssen schlafen.
Und während sie schlafen, war sie manchmal auf,
weil sie auf den Klo setzen sollte.
Sie hat den Neukomber.
Wie nennen wir das mit dem Fachbegriff?
Nektori.
Ja, eben.
Also eine, zwei Mal Nektori.
Sie beschwert sich über die komische Pusten.
Aber habe ich mich vergessen, wie war die Pusten?
Ich frage Sie auf jeden Fall, während ich völlig untersuche.
Sie hat diese Beschwerden seit sechs Wochen.
Und am Ende hat Sie richtig klar beschrieben,
dass sie eng gebrust hat, diese Gefühl hat.
Ein enger Gefühl in der Brust.
Ja, okay.
Und wenn sie sich belastet, ist es eher ein bisschen schwindelig.
Außerdem.
Und in Vorerkrankungen hat sie vor sechs Monaten
Vorhofflimmen diagnostiziert.
Und sie ist blödhoch zurück, ist auch ihr bekannt.
Sie ist acht Jahre alt.
Dafür nimmt sie auch die Besoprolol ein Tablete pro Tag ein.
Außerdem die Sionipril und Atowastatil.
Und Komedin auch.
Und außerdem hatte sie vorher eine Phankeatitis,
aber war es gar komplikationlos.
Und sie hat nichts gebracht.
Für die OPs vor zehn Jahren ist ihr eine Kindergelenkersatz-OP bekannt.
Aber die OP war gut gelaufen und keine andere Komplikationen.
Sie hat da keinen anderen Umfall.
Aber hat sie gegen die Amoxilin-Alegie.
Sie hat gerade gar keine Infektion beschrieben.
Ich habe schon Besonderes gefragt, ob sie zu Amphibie-Gelübchen-Thürme.
Im Vorfeld der Beschwerden, ob sie da einen Infekt hatte.
Ja, genau.
Aber sie ist es verneint.
Und sie hat gerade gar keinen Fieber.
Und ansonsten, sie ist zurzeit zwei bis drei Kilo zugenommen.
Sie hat zugenommen.
Sie hat sieben Jahre Paket geraucht.
Aber seit sechs Jahren brauche ich sie nicht mehr.
Sie trinkt zwei bis drei Bier pro Tag abends.
Außer dann seine Familienanwesel war unabhängig bis seine Vater.
Ihr Vater.
Ja, ihr Vater.
Ihr Vater ist, als er 80 Jahre alt war, so gestorben wegen der Knochenkrebs.
Und seiner Mutter, oder ihrer Mutter, ist auch bekannt, die Tümor.
Aber sie weiß nicht ganz genau, warum sie hat das gesagt.
Es kann wegen der Eistöße oder der Gebärmutter sein.
Aber die Mutter lebt noch.
Ja, sie lebt noch.
Sie ist allein Kinder.
Und außerdem hat sie drei Kinder.
Sie hatte alle drei Kinder mit den Normalen Geburt bekommen.
Und die Kinder sind auch gesund, bis die ein von ihnen.
Aber es geht um die eine Unfall, nicht die eine Krankheit.
So, wegen dieser Unfall braucht er eine Pflegekraft.
Aber die Mutter pflegt ihn nicht.
Sie kümmert sich um auch, aber gleichzeitig lieben sie nicht zusammen.
Okay, gut, sehr gut.
Ja, es ist ein
Ja, erstmal habe ich mir gedacht, dass es eine
Erz, als Krankheit sein soll.
Es geht um den Herz auf jeden Fall.
Ich denke so.
Und in diesem Fall kann ich nicht gerade die Name von die Krankheit nennen.
Ist es mir nicht angemeldet.
Kommt aber gerade rein. Lesen Sie mal.
Und konnten Sie lesen, was da stand?
Ja, das ist inzupfet.
Was wäre differential diagnostisch möglich?
In dieser Phase kann es dir, wir müssen erstmal die unterschiedlichen
Ob es geht von der linken Seite.
Sorry, sorry, ich habe etwas anderes gefragt.
Ich habe gefragt, was wäre differential diagnostisch möglich?
Ich kann wegen der Dunkelheit sein, in diesem Fall.
Ich kann dunkel emboli sein.
Oder ich kann, wie Sie geschrieben haben, die OP,
so kann man sagen, das auch.
Man kann diese Begegnung lernen.
Hier ist noch angegeben, pulmonale Hypertonie.
Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch jetzt?
Ich würde gerne erstmal, wie gesagt, die Blutabnehmen,
die EKG machen.
Und dann brauchen wir auf jeden Fall eine Echokardiographie
für die unterschiedliche Untersuchung mit den Herz.
Und dann gucken wir auf jeden Fall mit den Wandchen-Charles-Lungen.
Ja, ich wollte vorher noch von Ihnen wissen,
dass Sie genau im Labor wissen möchten?
Im Labor, wo Sie denn?
Wo nach, gucken Sie im Labor?
Ich würde gerne die Indie mehr von der Cardiac-Mostin
zu gucken.
Also die Herzentzimmer, wo nach, gucken Sie noch?
Ansonsten, ja, für die Lungenbülle,
gucken wir die Daimler.
Die Daimler.
Ich würde gerne auch die Infektion-Parameter angucken,
ob sie vorher eine Infektion hat,
ob sie die Herzklappen hat, eine Entzündung oder so.
Ja, genau.
Okay, da haben wir schon einiges.
Worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Ich würde gerne die Extremitäten, die Beine gucken,
ob sie die Dämmer haben.
Wo nach, gucken Sie noch?
Die Lippen und ob sie...
Ach so, ob sie blau ist?
Ja, das sind eigentlich schon die Hauptsachen.
Und Sie gucken nach dem Abdomen,
schauen Sie auf, ob da irgendwas geschwollen ist
oder ja, Lebermilz geschwollen oder so was.
Gut.
Was ist das für Sie?
Ich habe das schon.
Gut, wenn sich das jetzt tatsächlich rausstellt,
dass diese Patientin eine Herzinsuffizienz hat.
Ja, wovon wir jetzt mal ausgehen.
Was wäre denn da die richtige Behandlung?
Eigentlich.
Was würde die kriegen?
Sie kriegt fast alles, was sie braucht.
Die Bipoläule und die Söhnebilden,
die anderen, die die Söhnebilden.
Das ist ja auch eine Art,
die sie braucht, die Bipoläule und die Söhnebilden.
Die anderen Sachen.
Ich würde gerne, wenn Sie auch,
wenn man diese Dämmer hat,
würde ich gerne diese Anjur-Tinzin-Receptor-Blocken
und ein paar andere Medikamente hinzufügen.
Aber ansonsten würde ich gerne, glaube ich,
so Simulator aufhinsuffügen.
Aber ich nehme mich nicht gerade hinzu.
Das ist das, die Kardöter gecollege hier,
die ich hier mit der Stimmung machen kann.
Also, ich habe hier,
Sie hat, glaube ich, noch keinen Beta-Blocker, ne?
Nein, Sie hat Bipoläule hat Sie.
Ach, okay, ja.
Sie hat eine Beta-Blocker.
Okay, und hier, es ist noch erwähnt, Diuritika.
Ja, ähm, ja.
Dass man also da vielleicht noch ein bisschen was macht,
damit sie auch besser ausschwemmt.
Ja, gut.
Ja, äh, hier war dann noch, also als Folgebehandlung sozusagen,
ähm, äh, dass man unter Umständen,
wenn sie tatsächlich eine Engstelle hat,
ein Herzkatheter macht und dann dilatiert.
Und dann ist noch was Ungequemes dazugekommen,
nämlich die Änderung des Lebensstils.
Ja, richtig.
Ja, dass man, dass man praktisch der guten Frau rät,
das weiß ich, ähm, sich moderat zu belasten,
äh, weniger Bier zu trinken und auch ihr Gewicht zu achten oder so was, ne?
Gut.
Ähm, die Patientin fragt, warum habe ich denn mit,
an Gewicht zugenommen?
Ich wollte ja nicht irgendwie diese,
dem eigentlich gerade denken.
Genau, Wassereinlagerung.
Ähm, und sie fragt auch noch, muss sie im Krankenhaus bleiben?
Ja, wir sollen es,
die Muster bleiben, oder so, okay?
Ja, das ist ja auch eine Menge.
Gut, ähm, die Prüfer haben hier noch gefragt,
was ist Pulsoxymetrie?
Pulsoxymetrie bedeutet, ob wir,
ob unsere Herz, äh, nie,
ob unsere Blut genug äh,
Sauerstoff hat oder nicht und wir,
ob unsere genügend Sauerstoff hat oder nicht.
Ja, und wie stellt man das fest?
Ist das ein schwieriges Verfahren?
Nee, ist ganz einfach,
ist eine kleine Geräte,
dass wir unsere, äh, Finger,
Fingerkuppel?
Ja, Fingerkuppel.
Fingerkuppel,
so messen können.
Ja, sehr gut, ja.
Das war noch eine Frage, die die Prüfer hatten, genau.
Ja, ähm,
ich würde mal sagen, alles gut.
Gucken Sie mal nach der Patientin.
Ich bin gespannt, was bei ihren Untersuchungen rauskommt.
Ja, halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden.
Was aus Frau Berger wird.
Ja, gut.
Ähm, ja, möchte ich jemand, was dazu sagen?
Dr. Gündis hat applaudiert, habe ich gesehen, eben?
Nein.
Ich glaube, ein dickeres Lob können Sie nicht kriegen,
Dr. Attiti.
Wenn Dr. Gündis zufrieden ist,
dann dürfen Sie auch zufrieden sein.
Ja, danke schön.
Ich muss auch in dem Fall meine Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch verbessern,
so ich habe nicht so viel Erfahrung dafür.
So, ich meine, die Arzt-Patientgespräch kann ich sowieso machen,
weil ich die Umgangssprache gut kann,
aber Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch war auf jeden Fall mehr Übung.
Sie treffen den Nagel auf den Kopf, also, genau das ist es.
Sie waren im Arzt-Patientengespräch, waren Sie super.
Im Kollegengespräch waren Sie nicht, also, waren Sie so von der Sprache
nicht ganz so souverän, hat mich selber gewundert.
Ich hätte jetzt erwartet,